My name is Rona. I am a nurse. I want to
ask you said before that there are a lot
of similarities between Christian and
also Islam. So what is the role of woman
in Islam and in Christianity? Do we have
some similarities in the woman roles
itself? Thank you
>> sister. The question there similarity
with Islam and Christianity. Is there
any similarities between the roles of
women in Islam and Christianity? Yes
sister. Hijab.
The Muslim should wear hijab. The
Christians should wear hijab. That's the
difference thing. Christians are not
following the Bible. According to the
Bible, even the woman should cover their
head. Most of the Christian don't. So
they are not following the Bible. If you
see the photograph of Mother Mary, have
you seen the photograph of Mother Mary?
You have not seen the photograph of
Mother Mary. You have seen she's wearing
she's a mojaba. She's covering her hair.
She's wearing hijab. So many a times if
you know the true teachings of
Christianity and the true teachings of
Islam there are similarities but if you
know the teachings of the church the
teachings of the church takes a person
away from the truth
the teachings
of the Quran and the true teachings what
was there that was taught by Jesus
Christ peace be upon him it takes a
person towards almighty God. So in
Islam,
in Islam the women are respected. They
have to do the hijab.
But the status that is given to a woman
in the Quran is far higher than the
status given in the Bible.
In the Quran, the woman is uplifted
more. Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was the first human being in
the world who uplifted the woman to such
a high level and maintained it. You can
refer to my video cassette women's
rights in Islam which gives more answers
in detail. Thank you.